hey you can check out the original video
or through this link over there ish for
the original black rose also be sure to
check out the animation for the original
black rose right here not my crotch is a
damn fishin off when you can click my
crotch a cool hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to Black Rose now
this is an expansion to the original
black rose that I played a long time ago
that actually spawned one of my favorite
animations by Vayne Fox you find it
linked in the description below but this
is apparently an expansion upon that now
I don't know if it starts out in the
same way as last one did either the last
one was just a demo or this one is new
and it seems like this is the old one so
I might just wait no this looks stiff
burned visitation room I don't remember
that I guess they were pretty serious
about keeping this door shut I wonder if
the keys are around here somewhere wait
a minute is this actually different
is it not different oh it's not wait yes
no I don't know maybe it's a modified
version version okay so there's a keypad
over there I don't necessarily whoa
pain and suffering has warped their
bodies whose bodies my bodies certainly
not mine and I gotta remember that this
one was actually one of the best jump
scary games of the whole day indie
horror games that I played
is someone else here yeah I think I
think that's the same as before
so obviously since I played through this
particular part of the game before I'm
going to fast forward just to the jump
scares and this one so that that's all
you get and then in the next video or
later in the video of the same video
that you're watching right now we'll get
to the new stuff oh no turn
okay so was i q whoa hey how's it going
there all right excuse me
I know I've done this before so uh
pardon him Wow okay that seems new
that's different
all right welcome back everybody
oh damn Oh out here I don't know what I
did but I don't like it
oh okay so alright cool in not asking
you to speak to me but I made something
for you today at first I thought about
going out and picking you the prettiest
flowers I could find but decided not to
because why would I do that flowers are
beautiful but eventually they all die
instead I made you an origami rose paper
will never with it just like my love for
you this Rose is black because the love
we won't share it's gone it was lost in
the darkness and there's no ignoring
that however even if this love is no
longer mutual there's still one side
that will never die this Rose is our
symbol so uh Myrtle is overly attached
girlfriend so drop something
okay alright oh crap I don't have
another one
what do you mean lockdown enabled who's
locking down this place good okay we've
officially reached the new territory if
stuff that I have not seen before so
hopefully we're gonna get through this
just right now hello Myrtle sorry I keep
bothering you like this but officially
you're locked up so I'm just imagining
that you're not gonna come kill me there
might have been something else down here
that I needed maybe maybe not
I mean I got one key hello Myrtle you
okay in there alright fine bye
goodbye oh oh it's my first day working
here I felt a little strange no after
what happened that day things seem to be
getting even stranger I'd even go so far
as to say creepy creepy I've been an
embalmer for years now I'm very
passionate about my job weird
I've always felt comfortable with what I
do know
pretty unusual that I feel this way
that's what I said two of my colleagues
have died to bomb them both
however grief can't explain this feeling
up until just four days ago I hadn't
even known about the history of this
funeral home now where we are now
already knew that it was ridiculously
old huh
what I didn't know is that it allegedly
harbors some kind of powerful aura which
trapped in torments the spirits of
people who have died in a state of grief
or fear mm-hmm and have at some point
been associated with the building in one
way or another mm-hmm these associations
apparently include those occurring
postmortem such as embalming zand
funerals
oh so you think that would be something
that someone knows about if every single
person who had been embalmed or at a
funeral is trapped here and you know
whoa ferrozzo high odds go in there okay
this makes sense
I like this who the hell do you think
you are where are you going huh you want
to answer me but answer me very quietly
and calmly I'm just imagining I don't
need to go back down there again what I
mean frankly I oh he's gone are you
going ah
you're leading me okay I got you leave
me o stranger tell me where I need to go
oh look a page hmm mrs. Raines please
tell your son to stop playing under the
tables joint funeral services its
disruptive and upsetting to the grieving
families today he also stole one of the
keys to the visitation room and was
later attempting to open one of the
drawers in the morgue
this type of behavior it's unacceptable
and will not be tolerated
if you do not stop controlling him I
will take it upon myself to personally
teach him a lesson
Michael oh I thought I thought it was a
woman in one
but er ah so we're open now are we well
what is this ah okay well little weird
to make things even weirder
this place has a serious lockdown system
for a building that's also today was the
first time I've ever seen they use many
of the workers including myself were
ordered to wait in the family room until
the situation was taken care of no one
I've spoken to about it knows why it was
done or at least they won't say ah all I
know is that these safety glass windows
and electronic gates appear to be
designed for keeping things in rather
than out this isn't straight up SCP
containment [ __ ] going on here the
first responder that day was the first
and only person to make it to Myrtle's
side before she passed away she managed
to get Sullivan up Harding I love you on
that baby monitor but that was the last
communication they ever had hang the
last thing she ever did was give me that
piece of paper which one it was a short
poem she had written for Sullivan
earlier that day she asked me to give it
to him and I promised her I would then
she slipped away
I guess so then had picked up by
meadowsweet
rasping in the baby monitor that
something was happening to her because
soon after she had passed he came
running into the hall from the upstairs
arrangement room uh-huh
but he was too late she was gone that's
when he broke down I'd never seen him
show so much emotion towards Myrtle
before
then of course the rest happened thanks
for being dragged I'll keep my promise
even now it's all I can do for my dear
friends yeah your dear friends mr.
Morgan Wow hello oh okay oh oh okay
we're in it did we load it up at
different we loaded up a whole bunch of
different here okay so I guess I'll end
this part here thank you everybody so
much for watching I hope you enjoyed
this even though about half of this
video was probably stuff you've already
seen if you've seen Black Rose before
but I highly recommend going checking
out that animation the animation that
was made by Maine Fox and the other
stuff he's done you can check it out in
the annotations over there or in the
description below thank you everybody so
much for watching as always I will see
you in the next video